[Musica]
Ministro
posa
[Musica]
Parigi
Vado a vedere un po'
[Musica]
descrizione
di valore
[Musica]
bocca
mai
[Musica]
e
m
[Musica]
Haitiano
dobbiamo deridere quegli alti
sì
e adesso
[Musica]
e punto
io
[Musica]
per me
perché
[Musica]
ma timo
nerd
[Musica]
ma
Oh
[Musica]
e
Oh
[Musica]
sì
adesso
[Musica]
non devi dare
e il
[Musica]
e
tenente queste cose prestando che il
amore in una porta
addio
e
o no
[Musica]
quella funzione
Oh
no
un adulto
domani di questo
[Musica]
non più
prima del vecchio
[Musica]
[ride]
dolore
[Musica]
il tuo
potrei andare
amicizie
[Musica]
possediamo le polarità perché
noi eravamo
[Musica]
Oh
io
sanz
[Musica]
e sicuro
Ciao
e n
[Musica]
e io
intendo
[Musica]
leggero
e il lupo di più
ma
[Musica]
no
io
addio
bene
[Musica]
addio
è stato legato
[Musica]
ciao avventura mondiale ma no
leggero
perdono
[Musica]
io
addio
e più tardi
o no
[Musica]
è mangiare alle situazioni apprezzare questo
fiducia
avere paura del giorno del nulla
[ride]
[Musica]
ed entrambi probabilmente felici cure proteiche e
l'avevamo visto
per roccia
con super che mamme tra parentesi e cassiera
e il più forte è solo un tesoro di prigione
[Musica]
vieni e sicuramente uno dei
vicino di palme
se si stanno adattando vieni è come youtube
di r
ma non facciamo un punto
m
genere per una famiglia comica ma
bene perché l'hanno piantato un po'
grande
il calciooo na
niente
[Musica]
seminare un corso cosa perché coloma
sì
[Musica]
rimuovo
come una città
a
la grandezza anche se di renderlo adulto o
visto in procinto di avviare un politico
linea e un grande proprio
anche se ogni volta che dice
massiccio ciao la tempesta di libri mai
Visualizza
Spero che la cacca non mi manchi 20
e i Caraibi
[Musica]
il cielo e la capra